[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
new claims about the assassination of
civil rights leader malcolm x
the death bed confession pointing to a
conspiracy
nypd
this meticulously a wife
allegedly forced by her husband to saw
off her lover's head
asked to be released from jail
prosecutors say she could have escaped
but her defense calls her
a victim too the gun in her can her hand
shoot him she refused to do that
plus testimony in the no body murder
trial and we've got it here
for you law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
56 years of the day after malcolm x was
assassinated in new york city
his nephew says a police officer
confessed to his role in malcolm x's
murder
long crimes angenette levy is here with
the new revelations
yeah brian three men were initially
convicted of killing malcolm x
one readily admitted his involvement
while the other two
always said they were innocent this new
information
could actually help exonerate those two
men
who more personified
the black liberation movement
in america in 1965
than civil rights icon malcolm x
civil rights attorney ben crump stood
before a crowd over the weekend to
reveal that malcolm x's assassination
may have been the result of a conspiracy
between new york city police officers
and the fbi
a former nypd officer's family says it
involved luring his security guards into
a plot that would lead to their arrests
nypd and the fbi
orchestrated this meticulously
going to get the two people who
malcolm x depended on emotional security
the men were arrested and charged in a
plot to attack the statue of liberty
the cousin of former nypd detective ray
wood
an african-american officer in the 1960s
wrote a book about his uncle's 2011
death bed confession letter
he read from the letter in which he
wrote that his supervisor
actually cooked up the statue of liberty
scheme he lived in constant fear for
over 46 years
worried about what the nypd and the fbi
fbi would do to him and his family
if he had told the dark secrets
that he had held that helped destroy
black leaders and black power
organizations
malcolm x's two bodyguards were arrested
days before the assassination
so they weren't there to manage security
at the audubon ballroom
when he was killed i have requested this
information be held
until after i have passed away
any evidence that provides
greater insight into the truth
behind that terrible tragedy
should be thoroughly investigated
and ray wood actually died last november
and that is why that letter is coming
out now
in the letter wood said he had no idea
that malcolm x
was the intended target that day the
manhattan da's office is currently
reviewing the case to make sure there
are to see whether or not there were
mistakes made now thomas johnson
is one of the men who was convicted in
the case he has already died
but muhammad aziz he is 81 years old and
he wants to clear his name
the innocence project is actually
representing both men to help them do
that
brian thanks ange joining us today is
criminal defense attorney adam conte and
terry austin
terry this information seems to confirm
what many who followed the death or
assassination
to be more accurate of malcolm x
believed if this murder was in fact a
product of the fbi and went nypd
then what you know brian this has huge
ramifications because
if this is corroborated and
substantiated we could really see
an investigation of the nypd and the fbi
two things came out with this confession
one that they put this scheme together
for the statue of liberty
to take these security guards away from
malcolm x
and two they actually framed two
individuals so
i definitely think that we might see
some investigation as far as that's
concerned
and also a wrongful death action by
malcolm x's family
and possibly we could see you know other
charges as well
such as you know damages for a wrongful
conviction so
there's a lot to be seen here now adam
where are you in the authenticity of
this letter are you skeptical
excited angered where do you fall
i mean a little bit of all of it right
uh if this turns out to be true what
this letter says
it makes sense it's it's a logical flow
of how this event took place
um and so i'm not skeptical uh
i'd love to see it investigated i'd love
to see it looked into i would tell our
viewers to hold don't hold your breath
on a long-term investigation into the
fbi and practices of the manhattan da's
office
but i'd love to see that too yeah i i
wouldn't hold my breath or
or put a bet on that i know we we both
practice in the in the city here
uh adam i think we maybe have a little
more inside information on how they
investigate their own
uh and jeanette what about you it wasn't
just the two men who served time for the
murder
that ray would mention in his letter
correct
yeah that's right there were other
people mentioned in that letter
reggie wood the one who wrote his family
member who wrote the book last year
about all of this
he says that there were other people who
were either wrongfully convicted or
wrongfully accused of crimes
they were named in that letter he gave a
copy of that letter to the family
members of those people one of those
people
was actually tupac shakur's mother she
was arrested she was an activist back in
the 60s
she actually was put on trial and
represented herself at trial
she was acquitted of the charges and
then just you know about a month later
gave birth to
tupac shakur yeah great story
of course we'll keep eyes on this i know
that angie and i are deeply excited
about looking more into this malcolm x
case
and we will do so and give you back
anything we find thank you everyone
and now to colorado where an independent
probe into the death of
elijah mclean is accusing police and
paramedics of wrongdoings
23 year old elijah mclean died in august
2019
after being placed in a chokehold by
officers then sedated by paramedics
investigators commissioned by the aurora
city council say first responders were
flawed in their handling of the case
they say aurora police had no
justification to stop or use force to
detain mclean
police said at the time that a person
had reported he looked sketchy
the report went on to say that fire
rescue failed to corroborate
the claims that mcclain was suffering
from excited delirium before injecting
him with 500 milligrams of ketamine
a full presentation of the report is
expected at a city council meeting
still ahead on law and crime daily a
wife allegedly held at gunpoint
forced to decapitate her boyfriend but
first
the wisconsin trial of a husband accused
of killing his wife
testimony is back and you don't want to
miss it after the break
[Music]
welcome back testimony has resumed in
the wisconsin trial of a husband accused
of murdering his wife
and making her body disappear james
procopovich is charged with first-degree
intentional homicide he's accused of
killing his wife of 24 years
victoria procopovich in 2013.
investigators say it was part of his
plan to be with his new girlfriend
the defense claims the victim suffered
from mental health illnesses
and attempted suicide multiple times her
doctor says he treated her for anxiety
mood disorder and bipolar disorder
she stated that she feels so overwhelmed
and so frustrated
she reported that the reason for the
frustration definitely stems
from the medication she's on and the
number of the medicine
she needs to calm her down and calm her
anxiety
and her paranoia and her mood
instability
and her sense of isolation and how
abusive her husband is
and how disabled her son is who burned
himself by accident as a child
and when he was a young and now he is
jobless and totally dependent on her you
try to
note whether there is any any suicidal
or homicidal ideation
did you make any notation on this state
with respect to
that finding patient denied any suicidal
or homicidal thoughts
on cross the defense asked about when
the victim overdosed on medication in
2009.
the patient took an overdose her son
apparently
found her and she was confused
and disoriented and he called the the
police
and she was brought in a chain of events
ended on the psychiatric ward
where i met with her a day after her
admission
and this was because she felt like she
was having too much meds at that time
that she couldn't keep track of
everything
the clarity of what happened was unclear
what she overdosed on was unclear
she told me at one point she overdosed
on benadryl she did not admit that this
was
a suicide attempt or this was a
an intention to end her life rather she
made it sound
as if it is a very frustrated confused
person
who is just making
impulsive moves in different direction
to calm herself down
to reduce the anxiety to go to sleep
she's very upset
here to break down the no body murder
trial with a new judge is defense
attorney adam conte and terry austin
now terry the prosecution called the
doctor we just saw there
earlier today to try to show that
victoria wasn't suicidal at the time
but you thought their testimony also
helped the defense right
yes i think the prostitution did a great
job but i think the defense did a great
job too so the prosecutor was able to
show
that at the time she died she was taking
her medication
she was feeling better she was using her
coping skills
and she never really admitted that she
committed suicide you saw the clip there
but the defense came back on
cross-examination and he actually
established that the last time the
physician saw vicki
was nine months before and in fact she
was sometimes depressed
and sometimes she was you know happy so
i think that
the cross-examination really did
establish some doubt here and we'll see
what the jury decides at the end of the
day
yeah this is a boxing match going blow
for blow side by side
adam during the confidential performance
cross he said he never heard pro
capovich admit to killing
victoria just that she would never be
found how's that testimony going to
shape the trial
well it's interesting you know it's rare
that we get to see a trial where i
really think
i don't know how the prosecutor brought
this in front of a jury
but i truly don't in this situation i
don't see how they can
look a juror in the eye and say they can
prove this case beyond a reasonable
doubt
the confidential informant said that uh
that
the defendant had said uh not that he'd
killed her but that
that she was gone forever and they're
never gonna find her body well you know
who else said that
she said that the last time she tried to
commit suicide to her daughter
in the hospital she said next time
you're never going to find me
so i just don't see any level of
evidence here to really support these
charges
even the doctor that terry just talked
about just tried to describe the
defendant as
abusive but then when it came it came
time to talk about what that abusiveness
was
it was that he had said he was worried
about her medicine and medication
and that she that he wasn't sympathetic
enough for her medical conditions i i
just don't see this evidence
culminating in a guilty verdict here
yeah it doesn't seem as strong as they
may be presented to begin with but we'll
keep eyes on that trial as we continue
thank you still ahead on law and crime
daily what a one-sentence supreme court
ruling means for former president donald
trump
plus the lengths two florida women are
accused of taking to get a coven 19
vaccine
and authorities are saying it wasn't
their first time dressing up
as senior citizens next
the u.s supreme court has handed former
president trump a legal blow to his case
in new york
co-host terry austin explains brian the
ruling cleared the way for new york
prosecutor sy vance to obtain former
president donald trump's tax returns
new york is investigating trump for tax
fraud in connection with the trump
foundation
and alleged hush money payments the
documents will be subject to grand jury
secrecy
so at least for now the public will not
be able to see the records
trump has been fighting for years to
keep his tax return secret
and unlike former presidents trump
refused to disclose his tax returns
when he campaigned claiming that he
could not release the records
because he was being audited this
supreme court ruling will likely shed
some light on the case against
trump in new york terry denied
scotus gave no explanation or even
descends in denying the former
president's request
to block access to those taxes so how
could this affect the
current and future investigation into
criminal and civil cases
well you know if the tax returns remain
secret there won't be any real
impact on the other cases but there are
so many cases
against trump i believe that what this
is going to show
is the new york case is going to jump to
the top of the list
and by vance will have the information
that he needs to prosecute
remember now there are other cases like
in georgia and d.c they're pursuing
trump
for tax evasion and for fraud so i think
that they will
you know get in line to do that as well
and don't forget their state charges
against him as well and defamation
charges so he'll be fighting battles for
a long time
yeah a lot of those other states will
probably be looking to new york to see
what happens with his taxes here
to see if they can replicate or do the
same there thanks terry
turning now to other top legal news
making headlines we begin in the buckeye
state
ohio border patrol agents say a k-9 unit
is to thank
for sniffing out a cereal with a special
kind of frosting
narcotics detecting dog biko intercepted
a shipment of corn flakes
coated in cocaine customs authorities
say the package came into cincinnati
from south america and was headed to
hong kong after biko's alert
officers opened the box and saw the
flakes were in a grayish substance
the substance tested positive for
cocaine the 44 package has a reported
street value
of more than 2 million dollars a bomb
squad called out to investigate a
suspicious package in ohio
had a furry surprise the butler county
sheriff's office says when eunice moved
closer to the bag
left in front of a church they didn't
hear ticking but heard purring
inside was a dangerously adorable mama
cat in her six
one day old kittens a note said mom's
name is sprinkles and she went into
labor the day before
the feline friends are reportedly warm
cozy and fed at a local shelter
two women in florida are in the hot seat
for allegedly dressing up as grannies to
get their second vaccine dose
according to the state's health
department the women were caught faking
their birth dates
wearing gloves glasses and bonnets to
pose as senior citizens
the orange county sheriff's office says
the women were actually 34
and 44 years old authorities say they
don't know how they got away with it the
first time but their second go-around
deputies issued them a firm trespass
warning you know what you have done
you've stolen a vaccine from somebody
that needs it more than you
and now you're not going to get your
second one so that that's a whole waste
of time we just wasted here on this
if you come back any time you're going
to be arrested any questions about that
you're lucky to not be arrested right
[Music]
now
slightly comical but many senior
citizens looking to get that vaccine
when we come back a long a love triangle
gone horribly wrong
why a wife is saying she was forced to
decapitate her lover and her request to
get out of jail after the break
and we're back a new hampshire woman
accused of being forced by her own
husband
to saw off her lover's head will remain
behind bars
armando found text messages on
brittany's phone and then he beat her
in the bathroom of their home in
response to that
the way she described that was um he
grabbed me by the neck
and threw me down he showed me the phone
i'm quoting her
he put the gun in my mouth and i kept
screaming so he choked me so my girls
wouldn't hear me there's a state park
area where
our armando lured him there he beat mr
amaral
armando was armed with a gun um
he continued to beat brittany on the way
over
to that park it was immediately before
mr amaral was shot
where uh armando baron is in the
passenger seat of mr amarald's car
and he's made brittany get in the front
driver's seat because he's going to make
her driver car
and then armando gets out briefly
and the state says that in their motion
well she could have armed herself with
the machete in the car
and attacked armando when he came back
in
and the only reason they know about this
or any of this frankly is because
brittany told them about it
prosecutors say they agree that she was
a victim of domestic violence and have
charged her husband as such
but they cite her alleged actions after
the murder for reasons why she should
remain in custody
she made the choice to dis
excuse me decapitate jonathan to bury
his head separate from his body and in
her words
dump him in a brook in the woods to
leave him there
her own words when she was being walked
out of the woods by the
by fish and game was that she would oh
i'm in big
trouble it wasn't that she felt
endangered
the reason she wasn't talking to the
conservation officers is because she
knew she had been caught
and her admission of guilt or the fact
that she's stating
i'm in big trouble shows you her mindset
at that point it's not that she was
fearful
of armando it's she was fearful that she
was in trouble for her criminal choices
motion to amend uh modified bail
is denied and need the state's request
to
keep the preventative detention in order
is
granted back one last time to discuss
death decapitation duress is defense
attorney adam conte and terry austin
adam duress gets thrown around a lot as
a reason why people are
forced to do things and in court it's a
pretty rare defense but in this case
it doesn't seem too far-fetched to me
what do you think
yeah i mean the definition of duress is
being forced to do something that you
wouldn't otherwise do by fear of either
threats of violence or psychological
uh torture essentially she had both
happened she described a
horrific scene that was both
psychologically and physically
extremely violent uh her her
expectation of being able to fight her
way out wielding some machete
like an action hero just doesn't seem
realistic when she just had
the ever loving heck beaten out of her
and is
is in the midst of a murder i just think
that this
is absolutely a situation where the
duress defense would be appropriate
yeah tara we look at these photos right
here brittany baron and that
face i mean she had opportunities to
escape is what the prosecution is trying
to
argue if the facts are the way they are
presented and are true
then she was beat by her husband and saw
him being her husband
kill a man before her very eyes so is
brittany barron victim or criminal to
you
brian she absolutely is a victim here
there's no question i agree 100
with adam here look everybody responds
differently to
duress but she just witnessed the fact
that her husband
killed mercifully this individual and
beat him
and the fact that she was beaten i think
that
you know she might not have been able to
defend herself either with
a you know machete or even with a gun
and i think she feared the fact that if
she tried to defend herself
or even if she tried to save her lover's
life that in fact
her husband would turn that anger on her
and kill her as well so i think that
she's a victim here
and uh you know she hopefully will get
off on that yeah i'm calling it man
we'll see how the defense goes thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
along crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you